brent Barry Turner Sports NBA analyst
Brent good to have you back on how are
them CP salami homies good morning to
you guys alright if you're a Cavs fan do
you feel better or worse after last
night's performance Wow well you realize
that LeBron James is really special in
here stupid enough to not know that now
breaking news wait man hold on there we
go
[Music]
that's ABC is it not alright um yeah IV
I guess I guess you feel better because
you're on the board but it's curious I
really think that Nate's done a good job
obviously with with the team all year
with Indiana but in terms of his
preparation and how the Pacers are going
about things and what they're forcing
and it comes down to LeBron having to be
superhuman and that's the thing that's
crazy Dan is that he can do it I mean he
keeps doing it this guy and and saving
series and saving seasons for the
Cavaliers but I think you you feel you
feel better but you got to get somebody
to step up and let LeBron know that
they're along for the ride this year I
don't know did you get any news on the
Kevin Love was there any post game
severity of the hand injury uh yeah I
think he's gonna be ready for Game three
no I don't know if it's a strain
ligament did you guys see an official
update over there kind of but check on
his thumb I know that he got injured
last night but I think after the game
they cleared him said he would be ready
for Game three and now was the thumb it
wasn't related at all to the previous
metacarpal injury though do we know I
don't believe so but I made all the
headline I say he's expected to play
okay okay the only reason I bring that
up then as you know hand injuries or
foot injuries to those smaller bones
whenever it is that you come back and I
had to happen on my shooting hand at one
point it's still frail and it's still an
area that can you know legitimately just
be broken
and it's such a small bone and it's
still pretty weak when you return the
good news for kevin was that it was on
the offhand but you know good black like
that in the playoffs can can put you
right right back out so I'll be
interested to see if if the news is good
and how Kevin can can deal with the hand
because he's so vital for for what they
need at this point the way the team is
constructed III don't know what the
offensive philosophy was for Cleveland
last night with LeBron it almost felt
like it was like Russell Westbrook you
know last year
we're just hey guys you can keep up with
me great if not I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna take over here did you say Russell
Westbrook last year yeah all right okay
because I've seen some of that dish year
yeah I mean that's the kind of curious
thing about the Cavs going into the
playoffs and I think would every other
team in the Eastern Conference that
believes they have a a chance against
Cleveland is the fact that they just
haven't been together long enough and
they haven't had enough time on the
practice court especially with the most
important rotations of players that
they're going to need to have and this
goes really more more for every part of
the game not just the offense but
defensively in terms of strategy and
switching and terminology and and all
that kind of thing when you get into the
playoffs but yeah I mean it was
absolutely LeBron and let LeBron dictate
the offense and let him get to his spots
and if he hits you with the ball be
ready to shoot and and let's go and
that's problematic for them this year
with some of the teams that they
potentially could face and it's that's
showing itself even in this Indiana
series I can't help but think that
LeBron goes on the floor in these games
now and looks around and goes what the
hell am I doing with this group here
that he will not be with this group next
year what do you think III agree with
that I think this was the best that you
could do at the trade deadline to try to
reformulate recalculate and recalibrate
the team but this is a you know it's a
very interesting group of players that
have a lot of I guess
duplicated skillsets and aren't super
defined and what it is that they can do
in terms of shot creation and I mean
setting up players and being able to
create some things offensively that puts
LeBron in positions where he doesn't
have enough you know to do on a
particular possession and that's again
I'll go back to the fact that that and
the practice time and the amount of time
that they haven't had together it has
implications on how deep you can go and
also the investment emotionally and what
it is that this season represents for
Cleveland it's something that I talk
about with a lot of guys when they
change teams and they go to a team that
has expectations to do something one of
two things happens either you get there
and you're absorbed into and I'll use
the c-word the culture you're absorbed
into that right away and you want to do
everything you can because you
understand the importance of what's
going on or it goes the complete
opposite you go there and there's these
things that are talked about that you've
not even been around for that happened
six months ago a year and a half ago
that are still really important and
prevalent on the team's mind and the
franchise is mine and for you it's like
well how many minutes am i playing you
know what is it what do you what do you
need for me and so I think those guys
that came in this year probably fall
into the latter category about what it
is that this season is for them they
don't have the investment yet and if
they don't get it fast enough it'll be a
short season talking to Brent berry
Turner Sports he did the Blazers game
two against the pelicans he got game
four that's coming up Saturday on TNT
and then Game four you got thunder and
the Jazz Anthony Davis the pelicans that
surprised me you steal two games in
Portland maybe they didn't steal them
but you ended up winning two games and
how surprising was that yeah I'm trying
to get off the wording of stealing names
on the road Dan I mean I know we just
say that yeah but you can't unless a
team really folds in in Portland's case
to have a Liljegren McCollum score three
points in the first half of game
I mean what an anomaly that is they had
obviously had never done that so
Portland took it dance
or sorry no one else took advantage of
that but Game two is not a steel game -
I mean I got to see drew Holliday just
absolutely dominate a game from the
guard position on both ends of the floor
doing what he did against Lillard and
then having the kind of offensive
explosion in that game that was just
incredibly confident and looked like
this New Orleans team is really for real
the pace that they're playing with and
then the unmatchable Anthony Davis and
the confidence that he has I mean he is
he is something else would you start Jo
Ellen bead tonight I would you come back
from that kind of injury where it has
nothing to do with anything on the lower
extremities and it's above the neck and
he goes out he warms up I put them right
into the game and you know we start
rolling and you gotta you got to start
whatever this is for Philadelphia in
terms of their postseason and run for
and being to be on the floor as much as
possible and let him be comfortable
right away and find that out for
background find that out when he's what
he's comfortable with how he's doing how
he's moving but I started for sure I
know you got the news obviously about
your former coach pop with his wife
dying yeah I didn't want to start the
interview that way but I wanted to give
you an opportunity to let people know
yeah yeah I appreciate that then you
know having spent four seasons playing
for pop and then living here in San
Antonio and having the interaction that
I do with both him and RC Buford
throughout the year and seeing kids and
just around town pop as a coach always
stressed the importance of how
unimportant our basketball lives were
now it was important for the hour and a
half and two hours we were together but
in the overall scheme of things just how
unimportant it was for what it was that
we were doing and how the impact we
could make on the community really made
a lot more sense to me as much of a man
as Gregg Popovich is
that message came from home and Aaron
was a beautiful really lovely super kind
kind of mom of the team when it was that
she had her health and she's been
struggling for quite some time but for
people around here who know her and
honestly to know the kind of crap she
had to put up with with pop that's a
true statement that's what really that's
what really made us love her and that's
what really made the Spurs family I mean
they're really inner-workings tight it
part of the Spurs family appreciate what
it was that Aaron represented to Greg
and ultimately you know how if we spread
that when she could to the rest of the
Spurs family so she will be missed
it's very emotional here around town I
mean I was watching local sports around
San Antonio last night and you know you
know the way this town works dan is such
a small town one-horse town with the
Spurs but so many things on the news
about pop and about her and about the
relationship and it's gonna be very
interesting and emotional for the game
tonight pregame and to hear here are
some of the things that are said and how
pop handles it but she will be missed
and she was a lovely lovely woman
well-put Thank You Brent safe travels
thanks for joining us last quick thing
dude I'm sorry I miss you in San Antonio
I apologize - I had sent some barbecue
from my buddy at the Smoke Shack down to
you guys and you guys already had
barbecue at the event and it was just a
complete complete mess up on my part no
no I owe you no I owe you that and
enrich eyes and sent me back the
sweatpants because I sent it to Rich
Eisen the sweat pants from the dunk
contest cuz all you guys look the same
so I'm gonna send it to you Wow now get
it out to you wait when will this the
slam dunk sweat pants get here that I
don't know eysan just sent them back so
I'll reel able them properly and get
them to the DP show that's so nice of
you thank you you're a man of your word
Thank You Brent Thank You Brent berry
for more Dan Patrick show too
audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]